attention all units fugitive suspect
spotted at Grand in 17 do 23 25
responding just approaching the
intersection heading there now
unit 1835 we have a visual on the
suspect
come on it
[Music]
getting anything working on it
you seriously think she's here man she
was just two miles away
she's close closer than the last time
she was close she's moving
strangely yeah I'm pretty sure he just
likes keeping us out in the cold
look
there
well that's interesting told you
hey you're right no matter one yeah okay
you can warm me up later though I'm
gonna hold you that she's there inside
[Music]
it's okay you're just gonna talk okay oh
hey hold up wait a minute okay whoa whoa
calm down all right
you were the cops I can't go back we're
not cops
okay we heard you broke out of the
mutant detention center when we came
looking I don't understand who are you
just a couple of freaks same as you huh
Marcos
this is Lorna now trust me we have all
been where you are
roars we can help now come with us we
can get you someplace safe guys it's
trouble come on get dressed you're with
us down
what is it comes let's finish this way
kill the lights how many at least ten
from the west and south
this is the Atlanta Police Department
we know the fugitive is in the building
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody so a whole bunch of
footage just dropped for the gifted so I
figured this would be a good time to do
a non-spoilery episode one video just to
explain what's going on in this universe
how it's connected to the other x-men
Marvel stuff that's going on in which
mutants they're gonna be using at least
in the first couple of episodes
depending on how much you guys wanted
I'm totally willing to do videos for it
of all the new superhero TV shows this
looks like the most promising like
Inhumans is premiering tomorrow it does
not look so good I've already done a
non-spoilery review of that so I'll link
it at the end of this but just depending
on how much everybody wants it I'll
totally do weekly videos for the
episodes but it'll be a Monday night
show so I'll explain the schedule at the
end of this but as you can tell these
are basically x-men characters you may
know a little bit about it I did a
trailer video a while ago but they're
just using the opening scene here to
sort of set the stage and let you know
how their abilities work and what their
relationship is with the rest of the
world just to place this in the x-men
timeline this is in a period where they
believe that the x-men are dead now that
doesn't mean that they're dead it's just
that people believe that they're dead
but it's not as far in the future as a
movie like Logan like that movie is set
after the x-men are effectively dead
with a few exceptions this is a little
bit like a darkest timeline scenario
where you have a real world that's been
sort of co-opted by the villain group
which is called Sentinel services as you
can imagine there are sentinels that are
part of this series this is what they
look like but in order of appearance
these are the mutants that you spot so
Jamie Chung you probably recognize from
a whole bunch of other stuff she's
playing blink obviously you see that she
has portal abilities the other group she
runs into are the mutant resistance
they're sort of the good guys
but I know a lot of you are familiar
with the Brotherhood of mutants they're
sort of a sinister spin on that idea
like they want to get rid of all non
mutants they're not like that they'll
probably run into some mutants that they
tried to save who are kind of twisted
and evil and wind up killing a bunch of
people and they'll be really tragic but
for the most part they're good people so
you have thunderbird eclipse in Polaris
so Thunderbird you probably got a good
sense for his skills he can track people
he has a limited ability to see back in
time over localized areas when he's
focusing on specific people or things so
like if you asked him to
flashback 50 years into the past he
probably couldn't do it
Eclipse is like an alternate reality
version of sunspot he has the same basic
powers like when you see him get shot
his body just emits light he has some
pretty crazy photonic abilities he could
give off really destructive photonic
blast but he's a good guy like he's not
trying to kill these cops like Polaris
tries to at the end of the clip so
Polaris is one of the secret daughters
of magneto she has basically the same
powers that he does except she also uses
a lot of electromagnetic blasts as
projectiles in the way that magneto
doesn't so magneto tends to pick things
up and throw them at people she can
actually give off energy blasts if she
wants so that's really all you get from
this first 6 minutes there are a couple
of other characters that you don't see
in this there's Stephen Moyer who's one
of the main characters of the show he
plays one of the administrators at
Sentinel services so he starts off as a
bad guy but then his kids who you've
seen it a lot of the other trailers
develop powers so he and his wife amy
acker who I'm really happy as a part of
this series have to go on the run and
they sort of fall in with the resistance
these people here so because the story
is all about their family going on the
run with this mutant underground you
sort of have an opportunity to surface a
lot of cool mutants as you go along so
they haven't completely said all the
characters they're bringing on but I
believe it's supposed to be a 20 to 22
episode season I don't know what the
exact episode count is but like the
promo says it drops Monday nights so
I'll do more of an Easter Egg video
after that happens and if people really
like it I'll totally do weekly videos
for it like Inhumans for instance looks
like it's gonna be pretty bad so I
probably will not be doing weekly videos
for that maybe a season review at the
end of that but there's a couple new
comic book shows coming back this is
probably the best one this fall but
there's a couple other ones like Titans
which aren't dropping till next year so
Titans is still the one that I'm looking
forward to most but that's not gonna get
here for a while so just get ready for
all the shows to come back DC TV isn't
coming back for a couple weeks though
but you guys will see when I post
trailers so as long as you have alerts
enabled you'll just see everything as it
comes along
but everybody let me know in the
comments what do you think of this so
far and which of the new comic book
shows are you most excited about this
year now I'm talking about like the
brand-new one
obviously there's a lot of stuff that's
coming back but speaking of which what
will happen is is I was already working
on a stranger thing season 2 videos so
I'll post that next there's a new arrow
season 6 trailer so I'll do a video for
that too
so there's a bunch of marvel and DC
dropping in the next couple days but
I'll have some new Rick and Morty and
Game of Thrones so I'll just update the
video schedule when I post new videos so
while you wait for everything you can
click here for brand new Thor Ragnarok
and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight